right let's do it so we're going to jump
into a little bit of Crucible action
today this is uh my hunter uh EXO female
character uh which I'm starting to
actually I don't know if you can zoom in
on the anyways I'm starting to get some
gear that like looks Co cool as cooler
as well uh and I think that just sort of
reinforces my sort of feeling that get
get a little higher off up and then get
get cooler stuff yeah also to touch on
that that the touch on that note that
one gun that I was talking about that
you're going to see in a second also has
like a little bit of an effect to it
that all the other guns don't seem to
really kind of have that kind of makes
it look a little bit more unique and
that's not even a legendary item like
the purple item so that's also another
thing I want to see I want to see how
good these like really really good items
are so what's the level of all the items
there's uh it starts off with regular
like there's clear common and then it's
green green orange purple standard MMO
coloring is uh rare yeah and then purple
F yeah legendary yeah yeah anyway we're
going to hop into The Crucible this is
the multiplayer aspect of boy or just
join me hop on in there this is I
remember we we played this stuff I just
unlocked so I just played so we
basically this is uh domination you
capture an area and hold it this is Team
Deathmatch I just unlocked this one and
I'm trying to see how this is different
oh it's freefor all uh so we're going to
go into a team death match uh Tay and I
here and uh we'll see how it goes that
you had sort of had a glimpse of the map
earlier um we won't show too much of
that it's spoilery so oh really well I
mean it's you know it shows you where
venuses and stuff like that it's not
that bad but uh what I will show is I've
I've hit level 15 now right and that
allows you within your class I'm a
Hunter uh to get your subass so this
Gunslinger Hub subass is that Golden Gun
one that I played with all yesterday
that we saw through the beta this one
now is the blade dancer subass which I
just unlocked the ability I'm not
actually sure how works that well uh
charge your Blade with Arc Light
lightning and consume your foes with
lightning so it's a melee thing probably
actually not the one I want to use for
uh you never know like if if you're on a
point and you want to just go stabby
stab sure pretty I mean I'll use it
because it'll be fun and I'll try to
stab people and I definitely I find that
in in the competitive multiplayer for
Destiny so far I use different weapons
than I do in this in the I keep saying
single player but in the campaign
campaign what would you call it anyways
Outside The Crucible I use different
weapons than I would inside so for
example I prefer to use a hand Cannon
which is just a giant pistol uh but
inside The Crucible I use this burst
I've been using this burst file pulse
rifle an auto rifle is also really good
uh it just like higher fire rate seems
to work in your advantage also have this
shotgun which is actually not that great
compared to my other stuff but I'm not
I'm no good at sniping in like
competitive matches so where whereas I
go with a sniper for sure Outside The
Crucible I go with a shotgun here are
you guys waiting to get into a game yeah
so I have a question for
so this is a load screen so actually
we're just arriving so this is the
screen you see before you get into any
match oh the poor moon when you when you
got your subass right yeah did you feel
like it was like is it pretty different
from your other class or yeah your other
class because for me one's very kind of
more offensive Centric and then the
other one's more defensive so I was just
curious if yours has like a noticeable
difference uh this one seems to be hello
can you see me in the window nope you
didn't you got that guy you in the face
nice punch me we're on the same team oh
God I just get a little touchy sometimes
in the multiple multiplayer it wasn't
you it was the other guy also like a big
key uh important thing to note uh for
multiplayer is like trying to control
the heavy weapon ammo because like that
stuff Hurts the Most and so it only pops
up every now and then how many uh heavy
weapons are you allow to have on you at
any one time so you choose your load out
coming in and that's why you shouldn't
actually go into The Crucible until you
get your first heavy weapon there's
someone there where we were just at the
heavy is such a massive Advantage oh God
I don't know where anybody is what do
you guys mostly use then rocket launcher
or sniper or what I use the machine gun
machine gun yeah uh there's the rocket
launcher and the Machine Gun or the
heavy weapons I've encountered uh what
do you guys know of any others I use the
machine gun primarily and it's like
stunningly more powerful than anything
else I own to the point where like if
there's ever a boss in campaign mode or
anything else you better have heavy
heavy ammo on
you multiplayer to not have it just
seems like it would be
not just a disadvantage but a death
sentence yeah I mean because you're you
know you you actually don't you don't
get it too often cuz like Special ammo
is the green that I've been picking up
and that's basically your secondary
weapon my shotgun that pretty much
anyone can get generally speaking like
it's it's pretty abundant but the purple
ammo the heavy weapon like I you pick
that up and you know even without being
too careful you can pretty easily go on
a spre t You' got one here what the hell
is this thing so this is that gun I was
talking about it's it's essentially oh
crap he just uses special on me um yeah
I got special I got caught in that
special as well it's a pulse rifle that
shoots almost like
Elemental bullets even though it's like
it's still AR bullets it's still your
normal like main weapon bullet but it
shoots like electric pulses there's
heavy weapon ammo by the way yeah I saw
it come up but then it disappeared which
means someone has it somewh over here
though use on a dude who you okay I'm
looking got that big ass gun use it to
murder Some Space Magic Man
there's so much pressure thanks Annie
Chris how you finding this in relation
to like you're you've played a lot of
Halo you're a big halo fan uh obviously
it's not like an apples apples
comparison but is there any Crossover at
all in terms of play style floaty
jumpiness and whatnot work jump is a
little floaty but you have uh you have a
double jump and your double jump you
know depends on what your class is uh
so oh off the Jump nope it's not a jump
but I did get the double jump but I
didn't a where's the capture point
there's no C team dude okay I
was pretty much in any mode you just
kill the other people
though it's all kind of whatever all
right so I've got my machine gun now I'm
feeling a little bit cocky so not being
oh there near you there's one near you
yeah I got
him that's straight up Tommy Gun yeah
space Tommy gunm really big space I'm so
big I can't even keep all my bullets on
my inside isn't that kind that's one of
the criticisms as well I guess is that I
I guess Eric the gun you had there was
was pretty interesting but like largely
we basically looking at space pistol
space sniper rifle space automatic rifle
space Tommy Gun there isn't there a
sword at one stage yeah but it's only
for that one Mission oh really so
it oh didn't finish me off oh God my
health is very low oh good I got caught
on that stupid little ledge uh progress
from this bleeds over into the campaign
stuff as well right uh it does I mean XP
right you get XP and your XP is is
shared but there's no separate Crucible
XP there is a separate Crucible currency
called uh Crucible marks and like Deutch
marks yeah it allows you to buy and
level up or get gear that's specifically
is for The Crucible okay uh so that's
can you buy German soccer jerseys I
don't know okay you might I mean you
Angela Merkel
bobbleheads no there I have yet to
discover a bobblehead this isn't this
after all is not bored spongy you got to
collect um items as well to upgrade all
your stuff I found that interesting
Chris that you were finding that you
were like taking apart other items like
uncommon or rare items to obtain things
that you needed yeah yeah so for the
hunter like to get some of the bigger up
some of the upgrades on your weapons cuz
once you get uncommon and rare gear uh
you can upgrade it and which you got off
their bike oh you use the supercharge
stuff much in combat must be a lot
harder than the campaign right I
definitely do I mean I haven't used mine
I am supercharged right now I haven't
used it yet because it's a melee uh
maybe I'll use you right now maybe
there's someone in here I can stab oh
this is weird I've never used this
before so I don't actually you have two
daggers I think it's just straight melee
come on someone come get the ammo
someone come get you get items in here
too I guess how long is it you're going
to find someone the minute it cools down
you know that I really am oh
buts sorry guys
tried any uh customization on the
weapons at all unlocks and stuff oh yeah
so I mean you know some of the unlocks
just cost a little bit of money some of
them actually cost marks uh you have to
use like materials as well and so you
can get materials from if only you had
your swords suck magistrate death uh if
you can you know you use so like you'll
find gear you'll find like materials in
the world someone's got a ship oh I just
leveled up sweet someone's got a ship
though yeah uh so that's why you might
want to have have a rocket launcher oh
we lost so there weapons and turrets and
stuff as well in that particular level
that particular level has uh turrets and
vehicles uh on the moon that was moon
right yeah on the moon I'm not sure what
it's actually called I on the moon uh
that one has that it has it in
Domination as well other Maps I've
encountered on Team Deathmatch I think
I've played on like three other Maps uh
do not have vehicles or turrets and
that's another thing so the game's got
Vehicles right it's got the sparrow
which you cruise around on your like
land Speeder bike
I want I want like more vehicle stuff or
more specific like it's just a point A
to point B thing and like you saw
actually we showed some some footage
earlier about of us like just going up
this really h t uh tall Dune and like
cruising off the top and that was fun
like that's kind of make your own fun
stuff yeah but I feel like like uh you
know Borderlands with its multi and and
Halo with their multi-person vehicles
like the vehicle has a turret on it like
that is a lot of fun and it's actually
some good gameplay variety you have to
protect it you can like you can face
different enemies you can face enemy
Vehicles like that kind of thing I feel
like Destiny's ripe for uh you know
especially with this sort of sprawling
areas but there's only two right only
seen two right after the sand we did see
we we saw one of them one of rockets and
then one that shoots like laser Photon
beams you mean another vehicle yeah I've
only seen two that can actually fire
yeah so you have to steal those from
enemies uh in um in the campaign area
but you can also in like multiplayer
maps on that
match matches on that map specifically
you can get them they were in the beta
uh yeah some shoot missiles they have
different kind of boost stuff like that
but I don't know like riding with your
buddy in in a cars it's kind of weird
like I think we made the joke that it
would be cool to have a side car yeah
it's the same thing honestly with the
when you like compare it to being gun
crazy like you can get car crazy too you
want to try them all you want to find
them all and we feel like we did and you
want so many different even you know
ones that have like particular boosts
you know that go incredibly fast but
then slow way down those are great for
very particular instances and the fact
that like just finding all these
different types of of vehicles is a huge
addition of the fun of the game of
playing with your friends holy crap look
what I found one of the funnest things
when I was playing yesterday was when
Chris uh stabbed a dude and took the
pike vehicle the first time we had an
enemy vehicle and it was like one of
those moments when you play with your
friends when someone does something cool
and all the other guys go oh my God oh
my God oh my God and then like we found
a bunch of other Pike Vehicles there I
went oh my God oh my God I feel like
those moments didn't come enough when we
were playing like yeah it only happened
a few times yeah that's those are like
those amazing stories that you play you
know that you tell your other friends
when you play when you play games like
Borderlands like and then we found the
giant sword and we got on this giant
vehicle and we destroyed the ogre and
it's like I want more of those stories
we water's taking names got all the
names look at this oh I came around
thought dudes are on my back little
double to start things off not too
shabby come on T let's do it let's do a
victory go team Crucible guys hey uh you
obviously already completed the game uh
probably going to play a bunch more of
this over next couple weeks is this
Crucible stuff like are you interested
in in keeping up with it or is it like a
farming tool just for the single player
at this stage uh I think I think it's
cool that you can use it as a means to
still level up I think that's something
a lot of uh watch out what do you think
do I think are you enjoying doing this
stuff oh you were so I will after I get
through the PVE stuff like I want like
that's always been my focus like even
when I played wow or whatever I always
cared more about the PVP but or the PVE
sorry but that's me personally um I
think it's okay like I haven't Dove too
deep into this yet but I mean it's it's
always good to have a multiplayer well
okay I shouldn't say that it's good to
have a multiplayer if it's if it makes
sense like it makes sense to have a
multiplayer here right so you know one
thing I'm not super keen on in
multiplayer is the health bars the enemy
health bars which appear over your enemy
heads oh really oh yeah like it's right
I don't know just I I feel like there
are way better ways to handle that oh
God behind me that must be like one of
the first times that multipler Shooters
actually had enemy health bars on us eat
it come on I got a bunch of questions
coming multipler Shooters don't really
have that right oh God get away Question
Time H diversion on Twitch what is the
max level at the moment in Destiny T
what's the highest saw 30 is the hard
cap and then 20 is the like soft cap so
to speak is what I heard uh we saw that
24 yesterday yeah we saw a level 24
player yesterday that must have been a
Dev right oh gotcha uh ye yes because
you no there's no there's no way that we
were playing like with early copies
yesterday either a Dev or a cheater a
bungee player or an Activision player
something like that over there yeah
watch Bob Jones 99 ask we know the
release St for the first
expansion December did someone say
December yesterday I don't know if that
that's just what I heard but I don't
know if that's below or whatever
actually correct oh we all know about
the dark below I don't even understand
your euphemism
sometimes that a poop one I don't know
how many maps are in this bad boy it can
be a poop one they can all be poop ones
if you really
want how many Maps uh I don't know this
uh this is a new map I had not played on
uh personally so maybe there's five that
I've seen hello
friend this is a franchise that Bungie
wants to run for 10
years yeah well that's someone was
asking me on Twitter the other day like
why is the level cap so
low over there yeah well considering
like after a day Tay's already reached
over halfway and basically and beaten
story and yeah and like basically
already re almost reached the the the be
cool this time do it yeah get stabbed
you want to get stabbed too wo everyone
get stabbed we got stab party for
everybody someone's shooting me behind
me I don't know where they are oh you
got a shotgun to the face but it didn't
kill you for some reason stoed them with
bullets go crazy got two stab kills at
least yellow Sanchez asking a lot of
question people asking this question any
PC release date news no no nope has not
been announced nope they won't even
flirt with that I I'm sure they've heard
you if you're
curious keep badgering them like
everyone did with Rockstar usually work
o I upgraded I unlocked an upgrade for
my helmet I mean I assume it's just this
is a good time to look at that let's see
what upgrade I got for my it's just
impending so now I can oh well it's an
upgrade that's becomes available to
replenish Health each time I pick up an
orb of light but I have to get the
previous upgrade which requires some
gear that I don't have Tay you're
supercharged I know do something super
cool I got to do the slam dunk move I
got to find someone though it's probably
not easy to land either do these doors
okay believe in yourself stop being so
negative you got this oh thanks you're
not as terrible as you think believe in
yourself you idiot believe
it boom yeah I watched that that was
good that was really cool I think
there's another guy right you're so cool
Eric thanks oh no the door closed my
grenade I got Jinxed the door closed I
was going for the Triple and then I blew
it cuz I had my shotgun out uh Sam 7130
ask think Destiny is going to get better
with time or will it stay the same
that's a good question get better with
time I think it'll get better it will
more stuff to do they're going to I
don't know so far it's only gotten
better with time right I mean with our
time our first few hours we were like
all right we've done this before we've
seen it before um once you get into the
subass everyone starts getting really
excited that there's way more decisions
to be I know it's gotten that much
better I'm I'm skeptical personally I
like yeah any MMO or any like franchise
that is required like is is really
thinking about having a 10-year lifespan
probably needs to have a stronger
Foundation than what we're seeing here
but you might never finish Foundation I
think it's not come on drop down in
front of me like I like when Gears of
War one came out
like this game doesn't do anything new
and those types of franchises it's a
really polished much better version of
Borderlands with better shooting and
arguably actually probably worst story
like any game that like wants to have
that lasting appeal I feel like it
actually has to shake the boat and do
something new like I guess you know
maybe wow you could say was similar but
like nobody's going Topsy turv with this
bad boy even people who are enjoying it
aren't saying this is this is really
really good well sure uh but I mean is
so is there that's a good point like the
kind of success that we've seen from a
game that is like immediately just
captures everyone's imagination and sort
of dazzles people with something new or
exciting right that's not the kind of
game that Destiny is proving to be thus
far so uh what kind of game is is it is
there a different kind of nope nope he's
got his Golden Gun oh God man he's got
pul so that's not the kind of game
Destiny is at least for us here because
other people are having different
reactions other people are super I would
say that what what I was saying was was
a good median appreciation of what's
happening because even people on Twitter
I was asking this morning who who have
pre-ordered it are saying yeah it's it's
it's they're laying the same criticisms
that we were yeah so that the kind of
success that a game like the ones you
mentioned has found destiny may not find
so is there room for another kind of
success is there uh you know is there
sort of the long burn where like just
people keep talking about Destiny and
like oh I've played Destiny more yeah I
I'm really enjoying it the more I play
it like does that word of mouth grow do
do new expansion packs come along and
sort of reignite do they do they find
ways to attract people along the way
along the course of their sort of
10-year thing well let's let's lay that
up against something like Borderlands
which is a game that like people who
were very much much into Borderlands are
maybe looking forward to the Pre-Sequel
there's a which is a lot of people but
there's a bunch of people who are just
sick to death of it like we look at
where we at with something at Call of
Duty which is a you know fantastic game
well sorry sorry sorry Cod for a
fantastic game and it's had fantastic
games in it but they are like struggling
to reinvent that thing at this
stage later yeah but it's going to have
to this a game to have that sort of
long-term success like kind of has to
sell quite a lot at the start and I'm
not I don't know we I guess we'll find a
number soon but like
to me this is jury's Ash I sounds like
you don't like a lot of the marketing
Spiel that you do marke watch reading
games magazines and going to websites
long enough to you know forget all that
nonsense to me it's like it's just it's
a it's a really competent game and they
spent half a billion on it and that's
where it doesn't add up for
me there's just so much left to be
discovered at this stage is there though
after a day tay completed the single
player y it could have been faster uh
you feel about it but I also think
that's not the way the game like I said
I am still cautiously I've always been
cautiously optimistic about this game um
because oh he just killed me but anyways
like I got to I want to see all of it
before I totally judge it but at the
same time it's been kind of repetitive
like a lot of the fights have been kind
of repetitive I want I wanted cooler
things like the sword fight and all that
stuff that we saw early didn't really
see that towards the latter part of the
game I'm kind of curious if the raid
stuff's going to get make it better or
not
um but you're like you're somebody who
likes Diablo so it's not it's
not you don't necessarily don't like
repetitive games what is it the like
this game is not box is ticking the loot
there's not that much loot uh I mean yes
there's going to be legendaries and
whatnot but the diversity of the guns
it's not that big there's not that many
special effects to the guns like it's
just like you have a pulse rifer rifle
you have a better pulse rifle you have a
sniper rifle you have a better sniper
rifle in like Diablo there's many pieces
of armor armors that will change your
your skills and whatnot like and the
thing is even with the skills for um
like your classes now a lot of those
aren't like active skills right they're
not things that you're doing it's mainly
shooting grenade like grenade is like a
skill like one of your skills I guess um
but it's stuff like that like the the
depth of this game it just doesn't feel
that deep it's like you have you have a
gun you're shooting it's fun I mean it
looks great it's fun I just don't know
how long it's going to last for even
someone that me like me who like grinds
a lot of stuff like oh yeah like if they
can tell me there's going to be a
special gun or if there was even like a
melee weapon that we could have got like
that not just our fist or something like
that that you can get like that's cool
but I don't know that that's for me
personally so I'm optimistic about the
game but at the same time I'm kind of
like H I'm kind of feeling a little
sketchy about how long it's actually
going to last for me for me I don't know
about anyone else uh I feel like the way
I am feeling about Destiny now can kind
of be sort of summed up by the way I
feel about Destiny's storytelling right
I feel I sort of mentioned this before
but I think the the blocks of Mythology
of this this breed of aliens this breed
of aliens This calamity that happened
this world stuff like all that stuff is
there and it interests me but in a lot
of ways it's abstract I can only like
observe it I'm not like directly
connected to it by storytelling there's
not something that makes me necessarily
care more about more intrigued about one
type of alien than the other there's not
a lot of sort of direct access as the
player in terms of Storytelling at me to
get it so while I'm up I have seen
enough that I'm intrigued I'll probably
stay with it a little bit I totally get
that like the direct connection is not
really there and the story that the
dinklebot like that stuff is actually
pretty flat and it's pretty like cliche
like you were saying earlier Mary and so
I I feel like you know maybe that that
immediacy of experience that like you
pick it up you play it and like yeah
like even something like Mass Effect
where like at least in that respect you
you felt like you were engaged in this
world and you couldn't wait to you were
chomping it toit have some more yeah
like I never felt compelled to go
forward based on the story just or or on
the loot I was kind of just keep playing
because it was having fun with friends
Mass Effect for Mary you going to keep
playing this spot boy I know you play a
lot of Borderland yeah I think I I think
I will you know a lot of these things
that we're talking about all these
criticisms they're completely legitimate
and they they can't affect whether or
not you want to pick up that controller
and try it again uh and time and time
again the reason that I do play these
types of games
is to have really funny awesome things
happen with my friends those holy
moments with a group of buddies where
something happens that you know you
couldn't believe would actually happen I
do think it can happen in this game and
that's kind of what drives me back to it
you know like one of the issues we were
finding was with the with the dinkle B
all the stories are uh hey let's protect
uh dinkle while we uh we shoot all these
bad guys while he hacks something and
that happens y all the time all the time
it's like this consistent thing that
happens that's a it's like zero Quest
Variety in this game that's the one
thing like that's like a legitimate
criticism I totally agree and it's a
bummer um I will forgive that and I will
forget forgive a lot of other things
every time you find a massive sword and
slice a dude in half with it or when I
find out that I can pop a dude's head
off um you know and all this black
came out of his neck like there's cool
stuff that when they happen and you get
that sweet moment that will forgive
those criticisms but the criticisms are
legitimate yeah for sure all right go on
all right just last last thoughts for me
it's just like to hearken on her point
one it's got that Cod effect if your
friends are playing they're going to
message you you're going to play you're
going to do it um and then with the
skill things maybe we just haven't Dove
deep enough into them because like At
first I thought the subass for the Titan
was going to suck balls because it's
just a big Shield but I could see that
being used in spe very specific cases
and it could help you so this is very
early like yes I did technically beat
the story mode but maybe there's
something on the horizon I don't know I
hope well we've had a 24 hour or more to
to play it uh you guys uh can play it
right now it's available on a bunch of
platforms uh every Xbox and Playstation
you'd ever want to still own yeah so let
us know what you guys think uh the
review for Destiny will be up later on
the site we have a review in progress
that's up now uh the video review in
progress will be up uh pretty soon as
well Destiny Destiny Destiny Destiny we
will we be talking about it in a month
or two months or three months or four
months from now I guess only time will
tell thanks very much
oh